everybody welcome back to parka text and
for today I want to take a look at the
TV okay because that's been available
for quite a while and I really want to
get to it now and this is quite a large
scenario compared to the other ones so
far we need to get a total of a thousand
guests she's gonna be a bit more
difficult than everything so far the
operating profit with five thousand
dollars is also quite high and the
challenge goal here is to complete it
all within a year three which I'm
definitely not gonna make we all know
that but that's pretty tough when we
compare to some of the stuff that we've
seen so far so just in this area in
general also figuring that a Pico Harbor
and this can beat are gonna be quite
tough scenarios the difficulty really
seems the kind of ramp up in any case
let's get into this scenario and see
what it looks like I'm just pretending
that I don't know what this looks like
because I have seen this before first of
all I'm just gonna make the entrance
free because I'm nice like that I'm just
gonna make the rides more expensive but
yeah this is actually a really cool map
this is one of the scenarios that I
didn't make but when I first saw this I
was actually really impressed by how
nice of a sort of Island based scenario
this is with two dueling coasters in the
middle and you might know that I really
love dueling coasters I always built a
lot of them when I played rollercoaster
tycoon
so it's really cool to see something
like this here but aside from the
coasters and some basic scenery there
really see that there really isn't all
so much to the park so there's a lot of
room for expansion which we're gonna
need because we need to get a thousand
guests in this park so I think that'll
be all I'm just gonna turn on the
research and actually before I do that
check what kind of rides we have we
actually have a lot from the start
especially compared to all of the
scenarios so far definitely seems like a
scenario where they give you a lots a
lot of land a lot of rides but you also
need to get a very difficult go at the
same time we don't have very cool
coasters though so I'm definitely gonna
research the coasters first let's get
them researching coasters and
also I'm very curious about the stats of
these things yeah that's that's pretty
good so let's raise the price on that
quite a bit I think you can probably
raise it to $15 not entirely sure but
we'll see if they want to pay and if
people want to pay for that that's gonna
make us a lot of money so that is
basically it's I'm gonna try and come up
with a way to somehow bring this massive
Pike together and do something with this
path over here which pretty much leads
nowhere at the moment we'll see what I
can do with the park slats get started
all right so I'm starting out with the
wave swing or the chair swing which is
always such a good right to start out
with I think as it's especially good for
areas where paths kind of converge like
at the entrance of a park because it's a
really good ride so just put on display
and have people look at so I figured it
would be a good ride to start with and
then next to that I'm building an
entrance Plaza I figured this would be a
good place for a plaza instead of rights
from the starts because over here we
have that that small lake or well really
it's more of a pond I guess where the
coasters do that curve over it and I
thought that looks really cool it's it's
a nice water elements that kind of
provides some paths and coaster and an
environment interaction so I decided to
kind of make that the focus of this
Plaza kind of pointed toward that area
so people can look at the coasters walk
into the park see the coaster is kind of
in the distance and be like hey I want
to get into that so I think this works
out for a general simple structure of
this entrance area here and then my
final ride here is the carousel of
course it's a classic as well and I
decided to cover this thing even though
you don't necessarily need to put a roof
over a carousel because they already
have one it's something that you do
often see even with the the oldest steam
carousels so if you're looking for a
flat rides to design a roof or I think a
carousels honestly one of the better
ones to do that
I decided to go for a bit of a modern
flair this time around go for a glass
roof and to be honest I'm still not
really running out of ideas for these
roof covers this one is a little bit
similar to one that I've done earlier
but still everyone so far has had
different variations of colors and
pieces and shapes which is really fun to
design that said I don't know if I'm
gonna run out of ideas by the end of
this playthrough because I do intend to
finish all of the scenarios and by the
time we get to the last scenarios I've
probably built a lot of roofs for flat
rides but so far going pretty strong
there and hopefully I'll be able to keep
coming up with new ideas anyway moving
on from that I'm building a very small
food courts and it's really just this
small because there isn't much more
space this fight this is why I kind of
struggled actually coming up with a way
to use this entrance area because it's
really quite cramped so this food court
is just gonna be too simple stalls
really simple no big restaurant building
or anything like that so I'm gonna build
some food elsewhere in the park as well
kind of scatter that around especially
because the layout of the park is really
large as well and we've already got some
parts running throughout the entire
perimeter of the island so that's
something to keep in mind as well and
finally there's a toilet building
because this is just one of those little
gameplay elements that I am way too
prone to forgetting so I'm gonna try not
to forget these kinds of things this
time around and actually for this
scenario I'm really focusing a bit more
on the gameplay as opposed to just
scenery like I've been doing more so far
partly because the goal is just really
that huge because we need to get to a
thousand guests and $5,000 income a
month which is pretty sizable but also
just because I think in general I'm
gonna have to start shifting a little
bit more to gameplay focused play style
where I look a little bit more actually
micromanaging the park and working on
the economy because otherwise I might
actually start failing these things and
so far it's been quite a smooth ride
but I can't imagine what's gonna happen
if I end up completely destroying a park
that I already put a lot of effort into
and have to start over or something like
that so definitely don't want to get
into that kind of situation so I'm gonna
do my best to focus a bit more on the
management aspect of the game as well
and he'll I think the management and the
design are pretty intertwined even here
but I'll get back to that later in the
next real-time segments for now one of
the things I should probably notice that
I just built a staff room which is
another one of these things that I
always tend to forget so I'm getting
that in this time so hopefully my stuff
should be a little bit happier as well
and finally I want to get into the first
coaster of the park now I was
researching coasters to try and get a
type that I wanted to build and I ended
up getting the stand up coaster and at
first I felt well I don't want to build
this thing this thing sucks nobody likes
to stand up coaster but then I kind of
thought to myself I think it works out
all right with the layout of this park
we have this this flat area I kind of
needs to be filled and I think a stand
up coaster is good to do this with
because my intent with this park is to
make it sort of like a Magic Mountain
like just tangle of roller coasters on
that hill where you get different roller
coasters kind of interacting with each
other and all kind of conforming to the
terrain but when it comes to terrain
coasters stand-up coasters aren't really
that good at that they're they're
typically just a simple loop corkscrew
layouts with a helix and that's that so
if I want to fill this this this more
flat plane on this side of the island I
think something like a stand-up coaster
would work best so I ended up going with
this
I've been struggling for a while with
the layouts because I wanted to get two
loops in at the start but I ended up
going for one loop just because that fit
much better I know it seems like there
is a lot of open space here that I could
use that I wasn't really making use of
with the two loop layout ideas but
really in my mind I was trying to block
off a lot of the land that I have here
because I wanted to build a vertical
drop Tower
on top of that hill and another flat
right next to it as well so I want to
keep a lot of this area empty enough to
build some flat rides so there can be
more than just a coaster in this area so
that's why I was struggling to fit this
coaster in here because even though it
looks like I have a lot of space I was
trying to plan ahead a little bit and
kind of worked myself into a corner
there so yeah the layout is very simple
it's a stand up so go stand up coaster a
standard so go stand up coaster with a
loop two corkscrews and finally that
classic Togo helix of death which I
think this is a pretty good layout I
actually think it's more realistic than
the one that I had in Adventure Island
so a small improvement there and I think
it works a bit better with the park as
well this one is gonna have a bunch more
interaction with the paths and some of
the flat rides and the scenery that's
gonna be around it so altogether I'm
happy with this layouts and even with
the stand up coaster in general because
even though it's such an unpopular
opinion to to think that stand up
coasters are a fun coaster I think they
really are and well I guess
Marcel Voss actually has admitted that
his favorite coaster in roller coaster
tycoon is the stand up coaster but even
in that game it was kind of in popular
and now in real life it is definitely
unpopular because Togo in general as a
coaster manufacturers hated on by a lot
of coaster enthusiasts and the stand up
coasters aren't exactly the most popular
either nobody's really building them
anymore and they are slightly just being
dismantled so yeah it's not a great
thing but I personally like it
the only stand-up coaster that I've ever
been on was a Togo in Yomiuri land in
Tokyo but I thought it was really
enjoyable especially the the vertical
loop so I like these things and I'm down
to build them more in my scenarios in
the future as well now I'm running
behind a little bit again this is the
station building it's pretty simple and
very generic tropical feeling I think I
do like the the color scheme on this
because it is a play on the color scheme
of the coaster itself but one
I think actually works quite well and
doesn't feel like it's too forced with
that that dark pink roof and the green
walls which work really well I think
with the wooden beams and pillars which
just have their their beige-ish color
that I took from the buildings that are
already in the scenario so yeah I'm
pretty happy with this station actually
and with the right in general now I have
to apologize because I forgot to record
this next segment so I've been playing
the game for two hours just now and at
the end of it I realized that I didn't
record any of it so to try and make up
for that I'm just gonna have a slightly
longer real-time segment here where I'm
gonna go over what I've built and
explain some of the thought processes
behind it so yeah let's see alright so
here we are and the park looks
completely different already so this is
what I was talking about I wanted to get
this oh I still need to open that here
we go launched the drop tower and there
are some bumper cars over here I quite
actually like this this exit and
entrance path that we've got going here
although maybe I should put a sign at
the exits to try and prevent people from
walking in here thinking there's
something in there but yeah the whole
kind of jungle ish look - this area is
quite cool I think
and then the interaction that the the
stand up coaster has with the rest of
this area especially with the loop and
the corkscrew over the path I think
that's really cool in just one of these
ways where you can really put your rides
on this play now obviously there's this
other thing in this area now - and I'm
actually really proud of this one this
is one of my favourite layouts so far at
least for the flying coaster so yeah
this is a bnm flying coaster
am i running no I am running two trains
on this good so a decent capacity and a
decently thrilling coaster - I'm asking
for $15 to enter this ride as well and
the guests are paying for it so that's
pretty good and the layouts is something
that I struggled with quite a bit
because I wanted to make this as terrain
conforming as I
good so we have the area over here which
is quite high up I think even at the
bottom of this drop it's at seven
whereas at the bottom of this drop it's
around four so we go from the drop into
this this turn around to a fly to lie
and then back from a lie to fly into a
pretzel loop which is something that I
think works out quite well in Pike tech
it doesn't quite look like a pretzel
from this perspective in any case from
this perspective you can kind of see the
pretzel but yeah not quite as much not
not quite as pretzel like as they
typically are in real life but it's a
it's a very fun element and it works
really well on this game into a
corkscrew followed up by another twist
which is something fun as well I think
and finally some some curves because
there's not a lot of speed left at this
point in the layout and you can't really
go lower than this this area so I think
that's a good way to finish the ride
without losing too much speed and really
it's it's a decently realistic layout as
well I think I had the comments on the
last video that's a lot of my thrill
rides so far have been too slow and that
is that is definitely true to be honest
I I don't have a very good idea of
exactly how fast rides would be
realistically in this game because
everything is kind of up scaled the
guests are really big compared to the
rides so you know everything is you can
definitely tell what things are and you
can tell that they are based on
real-life rides but it's it's almost
sort of cartoony scale so to be honest I
always found it quite difficult to judge
exactly how fast things are going and
I'm mostly just building in a sense that
kind of feels right and to be honest I
think the speed of this ride feels right
it doesn't feel like it's flying too
high over this elements doesn't feel
like it's stalling for too long on top
of the pretzel loop here so honestly I
think the speed of most of the rides so
far has been fine it's much slower if
you compare it to a game like roller
coaster tycoon for instance but you know
if you consider
realistically this ride is kind of a
downscaled cartoonish version of a bnm
flying coaster
I think this speed works about alright
at least for me it feels natural I don't
know how you guys feel about it though
feel free to comment if you think I
should make the rides faster or if
they're good as is or if they should be
slower but personally I think something
like this feels just about fine but yeah
this thing is pretty intense also also
to be honest in real life they do have
some pretty insane g-forces especially
at the bottom of the pretzel loop and
this is something which is always kind
of contentious there are people that
really like this and people who don't
personally I love it but you get some
crazy high g-forces at the bottom of
these pretzel loops and because you're
lying in this section of the track a lot
of these forces are basically going to
your head and just the way that it feels
is is really intense and a lot of people
don't like it I think it's uncomfortable
personally I I do quite like it it's a
very unique experience nonetheless in
any case so yeah that's the the two
coasters that we've got and then there
are a couple of changes to the entrance
area there is some more foliage and put
a couple of umbrellas or well really
parasols there but that's really just
about it most of the changes are all in
this area altogether
I think this coaster is a good addition
to the park it works quite well with the
stand coaster as well that said I don't
know if I can somehow thread another
coaster through this area it looks like
it might be possible but it might also
be a stretch so I'm gonna see what I can
do there I'm still researching coasters
in the in the meantime I didn't research
any after building the flying coaster so
I don't have anything new yet but it
looks like I'm getting the wooden
coaster next that's not something that I
want to build here so I'll wait a little
bit more to see what else I'll gets but
yeah I do want to try if I can get some
kind of steel coaster into this area
maybe even have it go into this part of
the park
we'll see how that goes also I should
probably mention that the in-game
economy is doing pretty well I'm already
earning a $4,000 a month so really looks
like the guest goal might be the more
difficult one although that said I do
believe we have to hold the $5,000
probably for three months like it was
with the profits in archipelago
adventure so if that is the case it is
gonna be quite difficult to get to that
because as soon as it rains and people
start entering the rides less or you
know something happens something goes
wrong and you don't quite hit that
profit anymore it's probably gonna reset
and you have to start all over again so
even though it looks like I'm almost
reaching the goal I think I have to be
quite conservative there and say that
maybe I'm about halfway there
but yeah I'm doing pretty good in the
park I'm just gonna continue building
stuff we'll see what kind of coaster
we're gonna get and I hope I'm not gonna
forget to hit the record button this
time around let's let's go alright so I
actually did my job this time around and
hit the record button so I'm very proud
of myself for doing that and I can show
you guys some of the footage of what
I've been building so I started off with
this teacups ride because I wanted to
fill this area between the coaster and
the entrance of the coaster and just
create this whole sort of sub area where
you've got a bunch of buildings and flat
rides you know to kind of make the park
in general have the layouts of a sort of
series of smaller plazas with a lot of
buildings and rides around them and some
smaller connecting paths in between them
and I couldn't really settle on a roof
for this ride for a while but then
eventually I went with a Dutch gable
roof and actually a Dutch hip roof which
is weird I don't know why they why they
call these roofs Dutch as a Dutch person
myself I don't particularly recognise
this as anything typically Dutch maybe
it's a reference to Deutsche as in
German but even then I'm not even sure
where this term comes from can't find
anything about it all week
I do I was just wondering about this for
some reason if anybody knows why these
types of hip roofs are referred to as
being Dutch please let me know because I
have no idea anyway moving on I decided
to fill in the area between the stand up
coaster and the flying coaster with some
more toilets because I'm I haven't built
a toilet in this part of the park yet
and this part the this Park in general
is quite large so I'm gonna scatter as
many toilets around the park as I can
I'm not entirely sure about the stats of
guests as in how happy or unhappy they
gets if they don't have access to it
toilet but personally I think as a park
manager you have the ethical obligation
to the toilets almost everywhere because
I being stuck really having to be but
not being able to is one of the most
terrible things so this is a just an
important facility to put out there you
know and finally I've put a turbine on
the water front here which is a very
unusual ride to see for theme parks
usually these are more of a fairground
ride and I'm not sure how common they
are in American Fairgrounds but in
European ones you find them quite a bit
or the similar rides I'm not entirely
well-versed enough in fairground rides
to know exactly which model this is but
I know there are a lot of models of
boosters and related variations of
boosters and similar rights that are
common in fairgrounds throughout the
Netherlands in Germany at least so a bit
unusual but I thought it fits really
well on the water there so we have a bit
of a fairground right there and finally
I started on what is going to be the
last coaster of the park and like I
promised I wanted to make all the
coasters kind of hug this Hill here and
before I started on this one I really
had no idea what to do with it I had
barely any space left so I figured the
best course of action would be a
launched coaster I think it also fits
really well with the roster of coasters
that we have so far and this save some
space as well because don't need to
build a lift or you can just get
straight into the action so launching
into top hats just because I need to
avoid the coaster
down there and then I'm using some of
the available space that I do have to
build a Norwegian loop which is an
element that was pretty much first
starring on an intimate blitz coaster
like this so I think that's a very
fitting element and then we have some
lower segments which kind of emulates
Hilux in leesburg which is one of the
best courses that I've ever been on and
honestly a big inspiration for this ride
as well it's also a launched coaster
going up a hill and having very having
some elements very close to the ground
and very speedy it's just and altogether
really great layouts that is really
inspiring I think for launched coasters
so I was inspired by that to feature a
bunch of inversions as well as airtime
moments on this layouts and by the time
that we get down here having avoided
hitting all of the other coaster tracks
around the mountain I didn't want to add
too much else in the layouts I didn't
want to have a mid-course break run or
anything like that so we're ending with
a with a bang we still have quite a bit
of energy left as you move into the
break run there but altogether I think
it's a layout of a decent length and
decent intensity most of all it's
similar and inspired by speed monster in
Norway which is also the park that the
Norwegian loop elements is named after
so that's the last coaster I'm actually
really happy with this I really wasn't
expecting to be able to actually thread
a coaster through this super tight
jumble of coaster tracks on the mountain
there but it works out in the end and
the color scheme I'm also just lifting
straight from speed monster it's exactly
the same pretty much I guess the shade
of blue isn't entirely to say it isn't
entirely the same but overall it's very
similar I just think it works out really
well it complements the bright orange
and pink ish red of the stand up coaster
really well and then down below that is
the the two dueling coasters that the
scenario came with that pretty much
blend in with the rock were
then have a color that is super similar
to all of the rocks around it and again
this is the kind of coaster where I
really feel like it's a more recent
addition to the park
much like the speed monster or helix so
I'm going for a slightly more modern
style than the rest of the park so far
few more bright colors and modern style
buildings and also some modern lamps and
street furniture like that I just think
that works best for this area of the
park it's also at the back of the park
so realistically I think it makes sense
to make this the last area that the park
would have extended towards if it were
actually you know kind of built over
time as a real-life theme park would be
really the only critique I have of the
park is that it's a bit too thrilling
there is not a family coaster but to be
completely honest I've already built
enough family coasters at this point I
also didn't really see a good space to
build one and also I think the two
dueling coasters that you start out with
although they have some inversions and
things like that they are too intense
and they're definitely mo the most
family esque poster of the park so I
think that still works out not to
mention that the meaning of the word
family coaster I think has evolved quite
a bit in time one thing that I think is
really interesting and people don't
often discusses how roller coasters are
getting more and more intense as the
time goes on and I think this is mostly
visible on the record-breaking coasters
which are getting more and more
ridiculous with you know starting out
with coasts like king naka and then
getting to formula Rossa more recently
which is much faster and even existing
coasters like dodonpa just getting a
faster launch speed for the hell of it I
think overall there's a trend of course
is getting more intense and you can even
see this with family coasters cheetah
hunts is officially seen as a family
coaster
no if you look at that it is a launched
coaster it is quite a long layout and it
has some pretty intense elements in it
think a few day a few decades ago that
could have been a starship attraction
but today it's considered a family
coaster and I think that definitely says
something about how coasters have
evolved over time but yeah that's just a
small thought that I had about this
topic still doesn't make up for my lack
of a coaster for the kids but they're
just gonna have to man up and write this
ridiculous launch coaster up the
mountain so to catch up a little bit to
the video here I'm building somewhere
flat rights because I didn't really feel
like the park had enough flat rides as
much as I love building coasters you do
need to build some flat rights here and
there to make the park feel a bit more
realistic and once again this is a
toilet building because people are gonna
need to do their business on the toilet
as well that's pretty important and I'm
really just at this point trying to
finish up the park filling up the empty
spaces and adding some extra detail
where I figured fit and for the rides I
decided to go for the year the drop
tower that tilts you 90 degrees before
you talk down because that thing is just
so cool and I've actually been
researching the the drop towers for
quite a while because I was trying to
get drop towers and the researchers
wouldn't give me it so I had to work on
these two to actually get these things
so I'm happy that I finally got them and
then there's the orbiter which is a fun
and pretty intense flat ride and finally
the good old classic twister and for the
twister roof I decided to be a bit more
adventurous but in the end I really
liked this roof it's it's a weird
geometric shape the roof that probably
looks better from an isometric
perspective than it actually does from
the ground but I'm really happy with it
I think it works well in the surrounding
area as well the only thing that I kind
of choked on was the Q line didn't
really have space for another Q line
there so I ended up building the Q line
over a small Bay of the C which I think
actually works all the better it's a
it's a cool Q line that isn't just a
simple part next
right but it kind of goes out into its
own little landscape so I actually
really like that I until this point I
also have to mention I forgot to add a
cue to the teacups so if you've if
you've noticed that don't be afraid I'll
get back to that at some point as well I
noticed that I had no entrance when I
went back to it and realized I didn't
even a safe space to put an entrance in
so that was a bit of a puzzle
another puzzle was what to do with this
path on the water here because it is
super tight there's not a lot of space
on the left there's the coasters and the
right there's the sea so really the only
fret and the only flat rides that I
could fit in here without making it seem
too crammed are the ferris wheel and the
pirate ship which are always great
options to kind of save or some areas
where space is more tight because these
things have a really small footprint
especially the ferris wheel which along
with the with the motion the motion the
thingamajig you know what I mean the the
4d motion simulator there we go
that that along with that it has one of
the smallest footprints so from a
gameplay perspective if you run in if
you run out of space somewhere I think
these are the best flat rights to save
for a good location whereas with a lot
of the other flat rides like the twister
I think you can pretty much just place
those wherever you want and there you go
I I reached the goal again when I didn't
expect to so I wasn't really ready for
it but yeah this is the park I made it
and let's take a quick look at how it
looks so fun facts
I asked manager my way out of park
effects when I finished the scenario
because it was 3 a.m. by the time that I
was done and I didn't want to disturb
the household so I decided to leave the
game and come back to doing a commentary
over the last part later but then of
course I would have finished the
scenario and you wouldn't be able to see
me getting the trophy and I was like
well let's see if we can try and force
the game to show us the trophy animation
when I open the game at a different
point in time so that actually kind of
worked I just removed the process of
architect and task manager and I came
back to it now and this is the first
thing that
when I got into the scenario mode so
this actually works you can end the game
with task manager and it will still give
you the animation so this is what we got
this is the trophy I actually wanted to
show this because as soon as I opened
the game I pretty much realized that
this was going to be the trophy and I
think it's a really cool trophy
definitely one of my favorites so far
especially the way that it interacts
it's not just a building that it flops
down onto the map it's really the
entrance building with that little ship
that supposedly the people would arrive
on so that's really cool we don't get
any new Maps though looks like we've got
Biscayne Beach and happy ko Harbor for
us still that said I haven't prepared
any idea of what I'm gonna do with
either of these or what's which one I'm
gonna play first so we'll just have to
see in the next video which one I chose
but for now I would like to go back to
Batavia Cay one more time to check out
what the park finally looks like all
right so here's the park in it's
slightly leggy glory this is by far the
biggest Park of the playthrough so far
and I have way more people in the park
than I expected because basically I kept
all of the rights that I was building at
the last parts of the time lapses closed
so that I wouldn't prematurely reached
the goal which I did anyway and so by
the time I reached the goal I opened all
of these rights and a slew of new guests
enter the park and now the park is super
crowded and busy that's also kind of a
good thing I guess also I'm making eight
thousand dollars a month which is by far
the most that I've ever gotten and
really kind of feels like a coaster
capital very similar to the Six Flags
Magic Mountain even with the different
types of rides that we have it's not
exactly the same but especially with
that flyer going around kind of similar
to Tatsu I think there's a slight
resemblance there so we've already seen
these parts of the park
the flying coaster now looks a little
bit better with this new flat ride here
there's this very small Q line that I
couldn't expand on just because I forgot
to add a Q line to the teacups but it
works I think besides who's gonna ride
it teacups anyway and then of course
there is the launch code
which in my personal opinion is probably
the best coaster of the park really hits
a good speed on top of that top hats
down into this Norwegian look this is
one of the smoothest inversions that
I've ever been able to make in this game
I might actually want to look at this a
little bit because this is a trick that
you might also want to use in your own
coasters I discovered it when I was
building this but I'm gonna try and make
more use of that because I've never been
able to make such a smooth diving loop
in Pike sex see that it's pretty much
the whole layout into an Immelmann at
the end and finally into the brake run
and then you get a bit of interaction as
another coaster enters the layouts so
really cool coaster actually one of my
favorite layouts of the playthrough so
far and here's again that element so I'm
sorry guys I'm gonna have to close this
the basically the way that I got to it
is that this element is slightly hard
lined which is something that you can't
really do in park text per se but it's
it's it's it's in a way kind of
different because at first what I had is
I had a setup like this where it went
straight for two tiles and then it went
upside down like this but then I
realized that if you make this one piece
realistically this wouldn't be able to
be one piece because there's just no
piece like that but Auto connects allows
you to connect these two pieces and then
you get a piece where it starts rotating
here just before it starts getting into
the curve of the loop itself and there's
something about that which is super
glossy smooth you just have to set it to
one 1/4 slope up and then you get this
really smooth roll so honestly that's I
think my new way of making this
inversion be it a dive loop or an
Immelmann I think this works really well
for either inversion so yeah really cool
I'm gonna open this again to the people
and I'm really happy with the layout
partly for that reason and then finally
we have this small flat ride Plaza over
here just a small collection of flat
rides which at all quite popular as well
you can definitely see that the park in
general is very popular because all of
these queues are filled and
all of the cycles of the flat rides are
also almost completely full
the same goes for the coaster I haven't
or all of the coasters really I haven't
seen many empty trains looking around
the park
even the pirate ship has a decent amount
of people in it and the ferris wheel too
so yeah all together really successful
Park not sure if it's my favorite
scenery wise but the the focus here was
really on the coaster layouts which I
thought was a lot of fun to do I think
this is some of the the better layouts
of the playthrough so far and yeah even
though it's not the nicest looking Park
it also has just by far the best stats
when it comes to actual gameplay really
good economy here and I just have way
more money than I know what to do with
and kind of overshot the goal of the
scenario as well so that's it for today
thank you for watching guys and I'll see
you next time in happy Co harbor or what
was the other one there was another one
anyway I'll see you Biscayne Beach
that's it
we'll see anyway see you guys next time